en los últimos días el gobierno
ucraniano ha estado invitando a la
población de gerson que quiera abandonar
la ciudad a hacerlo creando las maneras
y poniendo no solamente a disposición
las líneas de tren sino algunos
servicios de autobús que los llevan
hasta la capital que fue hasta las
ciudades comodesa o micolife sin embargo
estamos en este momento en la estación
de tren de gerson y lo que nos
encontramos es que el número de personas
que intenta dejar la ciudad en las
últimas horas se ha incrementado y ya no
solamente por razones de falta de
infraestructura de escasez de
Electricidad falta de agua sino por el
miedo la guerra se ha acercado a la
gente de gerson antes cuando los
ucranianos atacaban y las fuerzas rusas
estaban aquí Ellos dicen que lo hacían
con mucha precisión las fuerzas
ucranianas pero ahora las fuerzas rusas
están bastante cercas y desde ayer están
atacando con mayor la intensidad la
ciudad lo que ha llevado a que muchas
personas especialmente familias con
niños y personas mayores dejen la ciudad